salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien dans cette vidéo vous allez
pouvoir regarder l'épisode 2 de ma série
sur Ragnar le Breton si vous n'avez pas
eu le premier épisode je vous recommande
d'aller le voir pour bien comprendre
l'histoire que j'essaye de raconter et
pour les plus impatients qui ont pas
envie d'attendre à la fin de cet épisode
sachez que tout est déjà disponible dans
la brut je vous mets un lien en
description voilà c'est tout pour le
moment bon visionnage toi qui est
combattant professionnel tu ne peux pas
faire ça c'est impossible tu peux pas
annuler un combat avec deux jours d'un
événement tu respectes pas les gens tu
te comportes comme un lâche moi même si
mes chances de gagner était comme ça
j'y vais
alors
moi j'ai l'impression que Ragnar fasse
au videur je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
passer de d'avoir une scène de baston ça
peut être marrant que le leader c'est le
premier mec baraque vraiment que Ryan
rencontre et que lui voit tout de suite
la DIV de niveau ils se disent ok c'est
bon
toujours à l'heure toi je vais dire
11h10
[Rires]
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait en reprend
tout un petit peu et on essaie de se
trouver les bonnes idées à chaque fois
pour faire avancer le récit ce qu'on
écrit c'est Ragnar devient une sensation
de tous Ragnar devient c'est un
phénomène aussi à France orange derrière
lui et donc il y a cet espace là qu'on a
pas encore développé parce qu'on n'est
pas c'est l'autre boulot là cette
semaine tu vois c'est quoi le pitch un
peu c'est un viking dans Paris
qui va faire les Jeux Olympiques un vrai
Viking avec une balade sur la gueule
très agressif un peu noté un peu brut de
décoffrage tu vois on va essayer de
mélanger les mondes et puis de
rentrer dans différents milieux sociaux
en France à travers ce personnage là qui
est complètement à part de la société on
va essayer de faire un film qui fait
plaisir aux gens et que dans lesquels on
se on s'éclate on s'autorise plein de
choses tu vois là sa carrière d'acteur
est lancé il a joué dans Astérix le chef
des légions au côté de Vincent Cassel il
a plusieurs apparitions dans plusieurs
films mais nous ce qu'on prépare
ensemble c'est son grand premier rôle au
cinéma après ce qu'on se met pas un tout
petit peu de gilet jaune pour raconter
une époque aussi
la voiture dans laquelle il monte en
stop
tu vois
vous ne passerez pas
aujourd'hui c'est les gilets jaunes
parties
des vaillants
j'ai un truc j'ai pris un coup à
l'entraînement depuis une semaine là
j'ai du mal à récupérer ma respiration
pendant 10
secondes
[Rires]
son spectacle qu'il fait il a aussi les
productions qu'on fait sur sur Instagram
plus tous les plateaux télé plus cet
entraînement dans la cage donc
humainement c'est impossible ça c'est
une réalité c'est impossible à mener
faut connaître l'animal c'est à dire que
il a une maladie qui est réel ça
s'appelle l'hyperactivité c'est à dire
que c'est tiré hyperactivité elle le
fait dormir deux à trois heures par nuit
je te mets au défi de le suivre c'est
impossible
[Musique]
je pensais que je pouvais gérer les deux
spectacle les combats déménagement les
enfants mon travail aussi ce que j'ai ma
société tu vois les vidéos les machins
et en fait
tu rentres le soir tu dis j'ai pas fait
60 % de ce que je devais faire tu vois
je dépose de petits je repars à Paris je
vais entraînement je vais récupérer mes
sacs pour la société tafta après je vais
répétition de théâtre je récupère le
petit à l'école
et puis du coup je négligeais certains
aspects je me suis dit je me suis posé
je dis allez
je concentre sur spectacle mais c'est de
faire un bon truc comme on aura juste à
peaufiner et après on fait le étape par
étape tu vois
[Musique]
on va sur Nantes
pour le matin je sors là non
non
on va sur Nantes pour le rodage du
spectacle voir les copains la famille et
puis tester des blagues quoi
avec mes auteurs formidables
Nasser tunisien du 78 asthmatique un peu
stressé et puis complètement possédé par
le diable qui se bat métisse sénégalais
franco-sénégalais
qui a écrit lascar et puis d'un cercle
qui a fait le spectacle d'Alban qui sont
deux auteurs très talentueux
un peu posséder un peu revanchard par
rapport à plein de choses mais super moi
je voulais faire un spectacle de one man
show enfin de stand-up parce que c'est
le
rapport direct avec les gens c'est plus
intéressant
moi des changes d'aller-retour en direct
tu vois c'est un truc qui dépend de toi
de ta performance donc c'est cool
j'ai envie de raconter des choses aussi
tu vois j'aurais transmettre aussi des
trucs que moi je suis sur le cœur tu
vois
il me dit un soir je vais monter sur
scène je vais faire one man show je quai
très bien dans un an dans deux ans le
temps que tu auras écrit ton spectacle
non non je monte dans une semaine je dis
mais tu vas monter pour dire quoi je
sais pas j'y vais à l'impro je disais
dingue c'est un suicide c'est une belle
ville
de plus en plus de punks je suis un par
contre
parce que il y a plus de punks
[Musique]
du mot clochard c'était Caron les
églises et payer des gens pauvres pour
tirer les cloches tu vois sauf que ça y
est les gens il y a plus de gens pauvre
qui tire les cloches pourtant tu
appelles quand même les mecs les
clochards
on dirait pas ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
spectacle ici
on va racheter des trucs
à tout à l'heure
avec des thèmes tu vois mais j'ai besoin
de travailler avant d'arriver à Paris
quoi je vais pas arriver comme ça ça va
être un fiasco total lâcher qui vont
être conscients qui vont être gentils
même si c'est pas drôle ils vont se
forcer à rire c'est bon pour la
confiance
il faut écrire le spectacle maintenant
et tu crois que il y a des gens qui vont
j'ai plein de personnes qui m'ont
demandé de venir je crois que c'est
complet ok au cas où tu avais des
enquêtes ou quoi
est-ce que les gens ne savent pas par
rapport à Mathias c'est qu'avant d'être
connu sur les réseaux sociaux
il a pris des cours de théâtre il s'est
inscrit et j'ai vu ce grand
Viking on va dire arriver et sur scène
très timide c'est introverti
comprenant peut-être même pas lui-même
ce qui faisait là
bonsoir Nantes en vrai franchement la
salle je me sens bien dessus elle est
super super
une catastrophe le plus dur pour moi
c'est ça c'est comme prendre le premier
coup ton cerveau il comprenne que tu vas
prendre un coup tu vois qui s'adapte
quand tu arrives ici comme ça et que tu
parles aux gens et de rester naturel
sans que le stress il envahissent
monter sur le plateau c'était compliqué
pour lui parfois il n'est pas pendant
des semaines
je voyais plus mais quand il était là je
sentais qu'il avait quelque chose à
raconter je sentais une expérience un
vécu une hypersensibilité très émotif je
me sens pas légitime c'est terrible
beaucoup plus et tout
un spectacle comme on dirait tout ça ça
met deux ans à faire deux trois ans ça
fait un mois qu'on travaille bon
c'est pas facile de faire de la scène
c'est un métier
[Musique]
tu regardes bien le public
pas ok
moi j'ai jamais parlé de de il veut
faire comédien machin jamais on a parlé
de ça tu vois
et jour je reçois une photo
Mathias coupe courte complètement et
notre sur une scène de théâtre avec un
micro
il est parti
moi je suis je bug comme ça quand je
vois la photo et je mets du temps à lui
répondre donc à mon avis il a dû
imaginer ma réaction de là
il est mort toi
je rigolais au début
c'est bien frérot et tout si ça te plaît
et de là il rigole je fais ça ça fait un
moment maintenant et tout je suis monté
sur scène et ça aide du ça aide dans
beaucoup de choses à s'exprimer à avoir
confiance en soi et les trucs comme ça
là tu vois
bonsoir
salam aleykoum
je suis tellement honoré d'être ici
non une ville d'alcoolique notoire
j'ai pas de texte je suis en un pro j'ai
rien écrit
je suis tétanisé derrière en vrai je
parle je suis pas en confiance tu vois
j'ai pété le micro
[Musique]
et tout mon corps se met en
la marque de fabrique
alors
[Applaudissements]
alors alors
[Musique]
moi tu as vu on commence dans une
construction là donc on a toujours des
petits
[Musique]
étapes c'est blinder chaque petit
passage pour que tu as vu dès que tu as
des trucs que tu sais que c'est sûr
c'est des trucs sur ça marche et il faut
que des trucs sur et que ça te laisse la
place à tes impôts ou tu sais que ça ça
bien sûr que c'est bien frère
en plus on est dans la construction donc
c'est bien c'est parfait
[Rires]
il s'est lancé sur scène et la salle
c'est marrée il y allait avec le cœur il
a dit salut j'ai pas de texte il a
commencé à déconner sur les quartiers
alors parler de ce qui connaissait et ça
s'est passé ça a marché et là il s'est
dit ben allez c'est parti tourner dans
toutes les villes de France et puis
après spectacle récurrent un mois après
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va Paris
ah non mais là il y a un nouveau fléau
les sports de combat c'est terrible
qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme mythomane dans
les salles pareil ceux qui changent vous
avez vu ceux qui sont comme ça là tu
prends des produits non non
je dis ça ce que tu as une veine qui
part de là jusqu'au trou de balle donc
tu me permets de moi quand je vois
Mathias timide et quand je le vois tout
seul sur scène à l'Européen devant tous
ces gens faut y aller quoi c'est pas
facile le seul en scène aujourd'hui on a
plus de on a pu la pudeur qu'on avait
avant aujourd'hui on va au restaurant on
filme ça bouffe
moi tu fais ça devant moi je t'encule
un peu
folles mais je crois que il s'est évalué
les situations et je pense que c'est
peut-être son passé de fauves sont
passées de la rue en fait son expérience
de la rue de l'humain j'ai toujours
pensé que il ne suffit pas d'avoir que
du talent
autre chose derrière tout ça ça
s'appelle le goût de l'aventure
l'adrénaline l'envie d'aller voir ce qui
se passe de l'autre côté de la colline
pour moi c'est un viking des temps
modernes là où tout le monde partirait
en courant lui il va y aller il va
foncer tête baissée comme cet
entraînement dans la cage
en tant que producteur de cinéma quand
il m'a dit j'ai combattre dans la cage
c'est lui arrive un truc on peut mettre
les films en danger en péril ton intérêt
aucun intérêt
ta part pour lui oui on sait que c'est
on sait que c'est à haut risque bien sûr
que c'est inquiétant parce que dans la
catégorie de poids dans laquelle il est
tout est arrivé on a vu des incidents
déjà
dramatiques
je pense que ça va être une thérapie
pour moi
il y a des cicatrices et des blessures
qui se refermont jamais
tu creuses un petit peu ce quelqu'un qui
souffre encore beaucoup
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de donner trop de
cartouches aux gens pour qu'il me
connaissent
[Musique]
j'espère que cet épisode de vous a donné
envie de voir le 3 pour les plus
impatients je rappelle que toute la
série est disponible dans la brut sinon
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine ici à
18h sur la chaîne Youtube de brut merci
encore pour votre soutien à très vite